okay so i prepared myself i got ready to
watch elizabeth hasselbeck on the view
do you feel that that's why i brought
this towel it's great for all of you
listen
strange
yeah
rosie o'donnell reviews elizabeth
hasselbeck's return to the view and well
it's upsetting safe to say she didn't
love her former co-hosts one day stint
back at the hot topics table and i have
this poster for the president which i
thought was even though i did not vote
for you you have my prayers because it's
a hard time and we should still be
praying for our leaders i watched it
from yesterday
and i remembered why
i don't want to watch it with her
anymore
her little post-it notes
i don't know listen
strange rose shared her unfiltered
thoughts on tick tock including this
message to viewers if you saw that
yesterday hope you recovered but some
fans well they weren't so happy with
rosie's comments
i hate her come on i thought i was
pretty nice in a follow-up video she
clarified her point of view
i didn't think it was hateful at all
it was just my review of the program
that's all
well it's not just a program it's this
program oh elizabeth i don't want you
know what you
you really don't understand what i'm
saying yeah rosie and elizabeth have
quite the history from their time
together on the panel their beef blew up
in 2007 with this infamous on-air split
screen argument because i don't
understand how there can be such hurt
feelings when all i did was say look why
don't you tell everybody what you said i
did that as well you did not defend me
it all started about the war in iraq and
spiraled into personal issues i can't
answer your own question i don't believe
that your suggestion
since september yes i have told you i
support the truth and the same for you i
asked you if you believed what the
republican pundits were saying yes you
said nothing and that's correct no no no
no no following the memorable blowout
rosie decided to quit the show i'm
minimizing my stress by leaving the view
fast forward to 2019 the feud was alive
again thanks to ladies who punch an
unauthorized tell-all about the show
there's still a little bit of attention
obviously yeah which people love yeah
the book aired out all the
behind-the-scenes secrets from the view
including rosie's crush on elizabeth
during their time on air i'll be very
honest i read it i immediately started
praying because i'm like how i'm going
to handle this in my old self would be
another split screen moment i think it
was disturbing to read those things and
it was offensive to me but i forgive her
i totally forgive you rosie while
elizabeth didn't love rosie's
confessions author ramin satuda told et
they were a major part of the show's
story it was really important for me to
talk to rosie o'donnell because i think
we needed to hear from her and have her
point of view in this book only time
will tell if the two will eventually
make amends
but in the meantime the view is moving
on to its next chapter with two new
co-hosts alyssa farah griffin and anna
navarro joining the table for season 26.
so i'm grateful for the for the platform
i'm grateful for the viewership um for
the relevancy and the importance and the
influence the view has it's an honor
there's no other word for it this show
is iconic i'm so excited
[Music]